[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe gefühlt schon eine Million Mal Buchteln gemacht
und auch gezeigt und auch in meinen Büchern.
Aber ich habe tatsächlich noch nie
das klassische Buchtelrezept für euch gefilmt.
Und da bekomme ich wirklich
immer ziemlich viele Nachfragen.
Und
ja, es ist halt immer so: "Sally, wie machst du sie?
Wie viele Buchteln brauche ich für welches Blech?"
Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
heute gibt es klassische Buchteln.
Die bestehen aus einem superlockeren,
sehr, sehr luftigen Hefeteig, für den ich
einen Würfel Hefe brauche,
20 Gramm Wasser,
80 Gramm Zucker,
ein halbes Kilo Mehl, also 500 Gramm,
einen Teelöffel Salz,
250 Gramm warme Milch,
zwei Eigelbe
und 120 Gramm weiche Butter.
Ich nehme jetzt zuerst den Würfel Hefe
und gebe den hierein.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch einen halben Würfel nehmen
und lasst dann dafür aber den Teig länger aufgehen.
Aber ein Würfel Hefe ist für mich
ist okay.
Zucker mit rein.
Und jetzt kurz die Hefe mit dem Zucker und Wasser verrühren.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
So.
Und jetzt kommen einfach die restlichen Zutaten rein.
Da einfach nur darauf achten, dass Salz und Fett
nicht direkt mit Hefe in Verbindung kommen.
Denn dann geht der Hefeteig nicht so gut auf.
Also, falls ihr mal das Problem hattet,
kann es womöglich daran liegen
oder daran, dass die Hefe schlecht war.
Ihr könnt auch eure Hefe testen,
indem ihr dieses Hefe-Wasser-Zucker-Gemisch
einfach abdeckt und etwa 15 Minuten aufgehen lasst.
Und wenn sich dann was tut,
also sich so Blubberbläschen bilden und die Hefe aufgeht,
ist sie perfekt.
Wenn sich dann noch nichts tut,
vielleicht noch mal 15 Minuten aufgehen lassen
an einem wärmeren Ort.
Und wenn sich dann immer noch nichts tut,
dann ist die Hefe vielleicht nicht mehr so gut.
Also so könnt ihr sie wirklich immer testen
und habt dann Gewissheit, dass euer Hefeteig was wird.
Ich gebe jetzt das Salz auf das Mehl,
die Milch dazu,
die Eigelbe
und zum Schluss das Fett,
also die weiche Butter.
Und ich benutze meistens sogar Dinkelmehl 630
oder einfach ganz normales Weizenmehl 405.
Und es kann einfach sein, dass ihr bis zu 30, 40 Gramm
mehr oder weniger Mehl braucht.
Und ich entscheide das aber immer dann,
wenn ich schon eine Weile geknetet habe,
dass einfach kein zu weicher Teig,
aber auch kein harter Teig entsteht.
Und lieber ein bisschen weniger Mehl benutzen
und später dazufügen,
als einen zu harten Hefeteig zu kneten.
So.
Ich knete den jetzt hier.
Ihr könnt ihn aber auch gern per Hand kneten
einfach für etwa 7 bis 10 Minuten.
Ich gebe hier noch direkt Hitze dazu,
34°C.
Dann geht er schon mal ein bisschen auf
und wird schön warm.
Und ich räume solang auf.
[Musik]
Ich fette jetzt hier meine Silikonmatte.
Der Teig ist perfekt geworden,
nicht zu weich, nicht zu fest.
Und ich brauche da jetzt auch gar kein Mehl mehr zusätzlich.
Wobei es anfangs echt so ausgesehen hat.
Aber durch das lange Kneten verspielt sich das wirklich.
Guckt mal. So schön weich darf er jetzt sein.
Und den forme ich jetzt hier schnell zu einer Kugel.
Das war es schon.
Jetzt die Schüssel fetten,
den Teig reinlegen und die Oberfläche fetten,
damit sie auch nicht austrocknet beim Aufgehen.
Und entweder lasst ihr den Teig jetzt einfach
bei Raumtemperatur abgedeckt aufgehen
oder im Backofen bei Gärstufe,
weil sich so die Back-
die Gärzeit einfach um die Hälfte verkürzt.
[Musik]
Mein Teig ist wunderbar aufgegangen
in kürzester Zeit.
Zum Fertigstellen brauche ich jetzt noch etwas Butter.
Die Buchteln sind einfach gut,
wenn sie mit reichlich Butter gemacht werden.
Dann schmecken sie auch am nächsten
und sogar am übernächsten Tag noch gut.
Obwohl es bei uns selten der Fall ist,
dass sie übrig bleiben.
Und ich fülle sie am liebsten
mit Aprikosen- oder Marillenmarmelade.
Bei mir ist es sogar eine Aprimira.
Denn ich habe einen Baum,
den hat mir der Christian damals empfohlen
vom Lebensraum Müller.
Das ist die Apr- Alp- Al-
Wie heißt sie?
Aprimira.
Ja, Aprikose, Mirabelle gekreuzt,
damit ich einfach die besten Früchte habe.
Der Stein löst sich super ab.
Und daraus mache ich gern meine Marmelade.
So.
Die habe ich jetzt hier.
Sehr lecker!
Immer mit Vanilleextrakt natürlich.
Und für die Mehlmenge, also für diese 500 Gramm,
nehme ich mein kleinstes Buchtelblech,
also mein kleinstes Ofenblech.
Da fragen auch immer viele danach.
Denn da könnt ihr im Prinzip
euch wirklich an den Blechen orientieren.
Das Blech mit 28 cm Durchmesser
ist für diese Mehlmenge perfekt, also für 500 Gramm Mehl.
Das Blech mit 32 cm Durchmesser ist für 750 Gramm Mehl.
Und das Blech mit 36 cm Durchmesser für ein Kilo Mehl.
Also da könnt ihr euch dann wirklich sagen,
kleines Blech Buchteln, mittleres Blech oder großes Blech.
Und dann passt es immer perfekt.
Was hier ganz gut ist, ich gebe die Butter hierein
und kann sie direkt im Blech schmelzen
einfach auf dem Herd,
weil wirklich die Bleche auch induktionsgeeignet sind.
Geht natürlich auch
auf einem ganz normalen Ceran- oder Kochfeld.
Und jetzt einfach so bei Stufe 1
so ein bisschen die Butter schmelzen.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
meine Buchteln formen.
Und dann mache ich es normalerweise mittlerweile so,
dass ich einfach den Teig hier rausnehme, forme
und direkt in die Form reingebe.
Aber, damit ihr es besser portionieren könnt,
könnt ihr es auch gerne rausnehmen,
den Teig einteilen.
Aber so mit der Zeit,
so nach dem dritten, vierten, fünften Mal Buchteln machen
hat man es dann auch raus, wie groß sie sein müssen,
und dann kann man es auch direkt
ohne Matte aus der Form in die Form machen
und spart sich noch ein bisschen Geschirr.
Also ich mache jetzt hier etwa 15 Stück.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich so ein kleines Teigstückchen
und öffne es in meiner Hand.
Nicht zu groß, damit einfach der Teig nicht zu dünn wird
und beim Zusammendrücken dann praktisch reißt.
Also das ist eigentlich so das,
was die meisten falsch machen.
Auch Samira zum Beispiel,
wenn ich ihr das zeige,
sage ich immer, nicht zu groß öffnen,
damit der Teig nicht dünn und rissig wird.
Und dann jetzt hier entweder mit einem Teelöffel
oder mit dem kleinsten Eisportionierer
die Menge rausnehmen.
Da nehme ich jetzt schon
so einen gehäuften Eisportionierer voll.
Und jetzt müsst ihr halt ganz schnell arbeiten,
damit die Marmelade nicht nach außen fließt.
Ich nehme erst die gegenüberliegenden Seiten
und bin wirklich ganz vorsichtig.
Mit den Fingerspitzen
drücke ich die Buchteln zusammen.
Und deswegen auch hier kein Mehl benutzen,
damit der Teig sofort klebt.
Und guckt mal.
Ich muss gar nichts machen
und die Buchtel ist schon perfekt rund.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr sie noch umdrehen
mit der Naht nach unten.
Und dann aber schon direkt ins Blech setzen.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr das in der Hand nicht formen könnt,
könnt ihr es auch gerne unten ablegen.
Da könnt ihr nämlich mit beiden Fingern sozusagen zupfen.
Und einfach wie so ein kleines Säckchen verschließen.
Und perfekt!
[Musik]
Ich liebe Buchteln!
Guckt mal. Ich bestreiche jetzt auch die Buchteln
direkt mit der Butter.
Und im Prinzip ist nur wichtig,
dass wirklich rundherum Butter ist.
Dann kriegt ihr zum einen die Buchteln später
schön voneinander abgelöst
und es schmeckt halt auch besser.
Und der Teig, der ist so luftig geworden,
dass die praktisch, während ich sie forme,
sofort weiter aufgeht.
Deswegen habe ich sie jetzt nicht mehr direkt reingelegt,
sondern wirklich gewartet.
Und ich hätte immer noch gern eins so in der Mitte.
Wow!
Und jetzt hier die Butter nehmen,
schön bestreichen.
Und jetzt könnt ihr sie im Prinzip noch mal aufgehen lassen,
abgedeckt.
Aber ich muss sagen,
dass der Teig immer so megaluftig ist.
Ich gebe den einfach, das ganze Blech in den kalten Backofen,
schalte dann den Ofen ein.
Wenn ihr wollt, noch Dampfstufe 1,
muss aber nicht sein.
Dadurch gehen sie noch mal extremer auf.
Und dann einfach backen.
Und da verlängert sich die Backzeit so um 5 bis 10 Minuten
im Vergleich zu dessen,
wenn man praktisch sie in den heißen Ofen gibt.
Aber ich finde, da spart man sich einfach
so eine gute halbe Stunde an Aufgehzeit.
[Musik]
30 Minuten waren perfekt.
Ich habe allerdings nach 15 Minuten den Dampf ausgemacht.
Denn die Buchteln sind jetzt schon perfekt aufgegangen.
Guckt sie euch an bitte.
Es ist einfach
wunderschön!
Jetzt lasse ich sie ganz kurz abkühlen
und dann werden sie mit süßem Schnee bestreut
oder mit Glitzerschnee
und dann serviert.
[Musik]
Ich benutze da, muss ich echt sagen,
ganz gerne Glitzerschnee,
weil es einfach eine tolle Alternative zu Puderzucker ist.
Und vor allem hat man einfach diese schöne Glitzeroptik,
die ihr jetzt vielleicht durch die Kamera gar nicht so seht,
aber hier so im wahren Leben in meiner Küche.
Es glitzert einfach,
es sieht wunderschön aus
und man hat es einfach nicht so süß,
wie wenn man jetzt Puderzucker darauf streut.
Alternativ könnt ihr auch süßen Schnee verwenden.
Das ist auch ein Puderzucker,
der nicht schmilzt auf der Oberfläche,
also auch nicht auf warmem Gebäck
oder auf Creme und Sahne,
genauso wie Glitzerschnee,
bleibt schön auf der Oberfläche stehen.
Man hat die Optik
und wirklich nicht zusätzlich noch mal gesüßt.
[Musik]
Die Buchteln werden gleich probiert von dem Karaoke-Trio.
Ich möchte sie euch gerne schon einmal vorstellen.
Hi, ich bin Sally.
>> JULIA: Geh du.
>> SALLY: Kommt!
Das ist Sarah.
Das ist Julia.
Und wir sind das Trio ohne Namen.
>> SARAH: Moment.
>> SALLY: Das ist unser Bandname!
>> JULIA: Trio ohne Namen!
>> SARAH: Ich dachte, wir heißen "Das Trio".
>> SALLY: Das Trio?
Wir heißen Das Trio.
[Musik]
>> SARAH: Kreativ.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]
>> SALLY & SARAH & JULIA: Money, money, money
must be funny
in a rich man's world.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung.
Habt ihr schon mal
solche weichen, fluffigen, luftigen Buchteln gesehen?
>> JULIA: Die glitzern?
>> SALLY: ... die glitzern?
>> SARAH: Nein.
>> SALLY: Nein.
Du ja.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Du hast schon oft genug bei mir fotografiert.
Aber du?
Nein.
>> JULIA: Nein, unsere Buchteln haben noch nie geglitzert.
>> SALLY: Okay, doch. Sie hat sie auch schon gegessen bei mir.
>> JULIA: Aber nicht mit Glitzer.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Ihr müsst euch jetzt nur eine teilen, denn
wir machen gleich noch Fotos.
>> JULIA: Oh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Zeig mal.
Warte, warte!
Bei dir hängt noch Ding drin
von der Marmelade,
Zimtstange.
>> JULIA: Vielleicht mochte ich die ja.
>> SALLY: Weil da war eine Marmelade,
>> SARAH: Bei dir hängt noch eine Zimtstange drin.
>> SALLY: die hatte ich praktisch noch vom Winter.
Das war die mit Zimt und die andere war halt mit Vanille.
>> SARAH: Zieht sie so eine ellenlange Stange.
>> JULIA: Sarah!
Okay. Komm.
>> SARAH: Entschuldigung.
Entschuldigung.
>> JOSH: Wahnsinn.
>> JULIA: Wir sind jetzt halt überzuckert heute.
>> SARAH: Ich hatte noch nichts Süßes heute.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JULIA: Dann stimmt es generell nicht.
>> SALLY: Oh, sind die luftig!
>> SARAH: Dann stimmt es von daheim auch nicht.
>> JULIA: Boah, mega!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Sagt mal was!
>> SARAH: Mega!
>> JULIA: Ich kann nicht. Ich bin am Schmatzen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Zimtig.
>> SALLY: Voll lecker!
>> SARAH: Sehr weihnachtlich.
>> SALLY: Ja, weil die eine...
Da habt ihr praktisch genau die erwischt
mit der Weihnachtsmarmelade.
Egal.
Ich wollte praktisch Resteverwertung machen
und habe gedacht, komm, die Mädels, die können das ab.
>> SARAH: Und bald ist ja schon wieder Weihnachten.
>> SALLY: Ich habe da noch die alte Marmelade rein.
Ja, aber man sieht,
im Winter macht man Marmelade und
die hält halt auch ewig
mit dem ganzen Zucker.
Ist halt so.
Was ihr übrigens auch machen könnt,
wenn ihr keine Marmelade mögt,
haut einfach Nougat rein.
>> SARAH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Josh ist so Team Nougat.
>> SARAH: Ich auch.
>> SALLY: Auch Team Zartbitter-Nougat-Creme.
Also Nougat in Buchteln ist auch immer der Oberhammer.
Ich hatte auch schon mal Mohnfüllung und so.
Aber so Marmelade und Nougat
sind für mich meine Lieblingsfüllungen.
>> SARAH: Wovon bist du Fan? Welche Füllung?
>> JULIA: Ich möchte noch was Herzhaftes.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Sie kriegt noch ihre herzhaften Buchteln mit Aioli.
>> JULIA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Die verspreche ich ihr schon seit drei Tagen.
>> SALLY: Aber
das Ding ist, meine Taktik ist praktisch,
ich habe Julia hierhergeholt...
Hört sich an wie, "ich habe sie aufgenommen
von der Straße".
>> SARAH: Sie bleibt so lange da, bis es Buchteln gibt.
>> SALLY: Genau! Genau!
>> JULIA: Sie hat mich auf der Straße gefunden.
>> SALLY: Und sie sagt halt die ganze Zeit:
"Ich will erst Buchteln mit Aioli, bevor ich gehe."
Also gibt es die nie, damit sie forever bleibt.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken
und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
Jetzt habe ich es dir verraten.
Ich mache dir Buchteln mit Aioli.
>> JULIA: Ich glaube dir eh nicht.
>> SALLY: Wollt ihr auch herzhafte Buchteln?
>> SARAH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Wollt ihr herzhafte Buchteln?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> JULIA: Ich muss einmal meine Hände waschen,
weil ich habe das schon an den Händen.
>> SALLY: Ich auch. Ich hatte so ein...
>> SARAH: Hast du gerade die Zuschauer gefragt?
Ich will auch herzhafte Buchteln.
>> SALLY: Okay.
[Musik]